25 years after roaring into theaters The
Lion King is back this time with a more
realistic look but is the remake really
more true to nature than the original to
be fair to Disney they did fix some
mistakes from the original version take
Rafiki in one scene in the 1994 film he
and Simba argue about which one of them
is a baboon it means you're a baboon and
I'm not clearly Simba is not a baboon
but neither is Rafiki he's a different
kind of monkey altogether a mandrill and
what's more Rafiki has a long tail yeah
in real life mandrels are nearly
tailless luckily disney fixes this
problem in the remake so now Rafiki
looks like the mandrill he's meant to be
but unfortunately Disney didn't get the
mandrels behavior quite right see how
they're swinging through the trees
yeah mandrels
don't really do that they spend most of
their time on the ground and when they
do take to the trees they walk across
the branches on all fours this swinging
behavior is actually more similar to how
a Gibbon moves but enough about mandles
what about the Lions of the Lion King
well there are a few problems there too
[Music]
[Applause]
take that iconic lion roar sounds
majestic right just like the famous MGM
roar here's the issue a lion's roar
doesn't sound like that this is a roar
it's not quite as majestic as what you
hear in the movie but that sound can
still travel up to eight kilometers away
[Music]
some of the liens behavior is also off
and that's not including talking with
ghosts
watch how Simba scampers off with his
dad it's a touching scene but in real
life Surabhi would never let Simba out
of her sight while lion cubs do play
with their fathers their mothers are
extremely protective and you can't blame
them because if a new male comes to town
and takes over the pride he'll try to
kill their young cubs sound familiar
that's right scar schemed to usurp
Mufasa was in line with normal lion
behavior except his methods were rather
unconventional because lions and hyenas
don't work together ever in fact there
are major competitors for food in the
wild so it's hard to believe that a lion
could convince a horde of hyenas to do
his dirty work even with a catchy
villain Saad
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]